wenn ich dieses stück politisch lage
zerbricht
das macht mir nicht vorstellen dass wir
zu einem neuen video heute mit am start
des videos
leute wir sind gerade ultra fertig ich
hatte heute neun stunden dreh habt dann
nachdem ein video geschnitten fielen
auch schon geschlafen davor max auch
holte früh aufgestanden als zwei
klausuren in der uni geschliffen und
auch mega viel gelernt das heißt wisse
eigentlich fertig und heute ist der die
alles hat um diese versuche nicht zu
lachen challenger aufzunehmen weil wir
einfach am ehesten heute nicht lachen
wenn wir es heute schaffen
und natürlich ist die grundlage wieder
youtube treffe leute runter jetzt habe
ich die werden jetzt steigen und steigen
und steigen
und hab dann geld verdient ohne ein
fräulein zu finden ich bin gern wissen
sie über eine gute ernte da warst du
schon mal so nach hat das ist ein ziel
ist um geld verdienen kann
ich habe nicht dich 30 gehen und bar
bezahlen er lustig sonst ist es doch
eine nachnahme tut mir leid sie wird los
er hatte noch fragen gelten kurse bis
2020 20
das auch noch allerhand ausländisches
geld dabei das können sie doch um
porsche um so ein schönes trinke ich bin
doch kein kellner
[Gelächter]
wie wäre es denn mit einem tausch dieses
schöne ziele mond gegen das päckchen die
sind doch hier nicht bald 11 außerdem
stellen sie sich vor jeder kunde würde
mir sein scheiß andrehen der eine sein
rad vater der anderen ölgemälde der
anderen art gemälde der anderen seite
anderer kenner der eine seite moneymaker
software was los in höhe von gesehen der
heutige überhaupt nicht erwarten die
sonne wird sollte galileo ist in dem
schreiben verlinkt unten lassen bei
bedarf als noch nicht gemacht haben ich
[Gelächter]
möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen
das video von galilei leute aber hier
haben wir noch ein video
soßenbinder auch glaube ich der von dem
ich die erste youtube attraktion dar ich
gemacht habe vor ewigkeiten und er hat
einen herauskommen was absolut ist und
zwar youtube kacke das volk der künstler
selbst den übrigens von solche begriffe
in dem wörter fallen leute und da regt
euch nicht auf lasst euch nicht
schwieriger ist einfach spaß ihres
spinds vertreten
bald schon werden sie gratulieren die
geschichte beginnt im jahr 420 nach
christus
auch wenn die hauptakteure häufigkeit
des skandinavien waren steht der begriff
für keine nationale identität
die menschen auf den höfen hätten sich
niemals väter genannt
sie sagten er geschlechtsverkehr
menschen die arabischer clan hat uns
genaue berichte über die frauen der
wixxer hinterlassen
er schreibt große posten nicht will
gucken nicht will dich küssen von allen
geschöpfen gottes sind sie die
schmutzigsten diesen tagen hört die
stiftung heute nicht überraschen
gleichzeitig danken megane ganze leute
aber jetzt haben wir komplett verkannt
ich sparen im zehnten jahrhundert
bemerkte ein aber einmal dass die wixxer
für bunte lange karte kupplung alles
geben probsthain halbjahr an
ich habe zwei schwänze eigentlich dieses
stück politische lage zerbricht das doch
das macht mich vor staat lösen
[Gelächter]
die fünf minuten von q cells und
passanten außergewöhnlich weil sie fünf
verschiedene typen unterschiedlicher
hersteller
ludwig stammt aus irland 2 aus irland
und zwei aus irland maxis werner und
erika nyström wie diese scheiden
gesegelt worden wo sie auch hin fuhren
nach osten westen norden oder nordwesten
oder südosten oder darauf süden oder sie
lösen
es war die außergewöhnliche gestank ihre
hellen der ein halbes jahrtausend lang
über dauerte heute applaus für den
einzig wahren krankhafter habt ihr im
video nach hause haben den lachen ja
leute an der stelle würde ich sagen will
der und galilei sind bei der
beschreibung vor dem check die auf jeden
fall ab ich habe an der stelle in diesem
video heute natürlich nicht gelacht max
dann doch ein bisschen mehr verkackt
schade für ihn besser und dann bleibt
nur noch eins zu sagen